Chloe and I have a really good thing
going on right now I'm like the real one
with her of like what goes down how it's
gonna go down you're lying
Chloe what advice are you giving her is
there one thing that you say you have no
idea this is coming for you your nipples
are gonna be so raw like you don't you
don't even know you cannot tell her
anything right now that's too sensitive
because she's just so freaked out yep so
I can't really get into the whole like
nipple breastfeeding thing um she's just
gonna have to like figure that all out
and slowly and it'll be fine she's she
knows I mean she's seen all of us go
through it yeah she's prepared but I
feel like her and I just are on a really
good like communication about everything
but I know when to push it and when to
want you right now is not a time to
freak her out yep
just makes it closer it gets you can't
like freak someone out cuz this is you
like have to think back to like first
baby like you've no idea what you're
doing no idea and that's okay that's the
beauty of it yeah you just have no clue
and that's totally fine Kim Kardashian
opening up to et about her sister
Chloe's impending motherhood while
celebrating the launch of her new k'kaw
beauty collaboration with her longtime
makeup artist Mario it's available in
stores on a special day for the duo
so you're launching this on the day when
you met ten years ago yes April 5th
we met in 2008 on a photo shoot and from
the moment he did my makeup I just felt
like myself I can't explain it I just
was like like I'm obsessed with you
and what do you remember about her
walking in it well she was a rising star
at the time in the United States I was
super excited and I just remember her
being incredibly sweet incredibly kind
and she was taking selfies the entire
time on a camera on a camera I went to
[Music]